musone tutti ragazzini tra i dati su
l'episodio di video correlati allora a
me piace tantissimo registrarlo visto
che a livello di feedback è piaciuto un
sacco anche a voi ma chi non sapesse di
cosa sto parlando ve lo spiega il volo
per chi mente questa sorta di challenge
tv dovere lati consiste nel passare da
una parola ad un'altra che non c'entra
completamente niente tramite video
correlati youtube quindi se cerchiamo
nel senso bisogno fatto tipo salvini e
aver già sendin idolo a primo video di
salvini e da quello solo con i video
correlati arrivare ad avengers il primo
abbinamento ragazzi che faremo oggi sarà
da death note devo arrivare ad aldo
giovanni e giacomo
[Musica]
ora andiamo lì video correlati io se
usciamo a beccare qualcosa dobbiamo
uscire ovviamente da detto non perché
sono veramente impossibile ci sono le
space valigia potrebbe questo questo non
è space valeva fa niente grazie a
youtube che funzioni sempre benissimo
devo veramente mag allontanarmi facciamo
sushi questo era mette il casinò laga
perché non trova il nesso ma il mare
anche da lontanissimo cava calcutta
testo va bene da calcutta facciamo
paracetamolo va bene una ragazza
impossibile che la perché i per il se
continuiamo a stare sulla rai on
nell'occhio e bisogno cercato di andare
sulla musica non la trovo mai leso
tuttomusica porco demonio eugenio in val
di gioia cosa mi manchi a fare posso io
devo uscire dalla musica vi sono
incartato nella musica aiuto sanremo
prova a mettere sanremo per vedere se
riesce a portarmi via da qualcosa mara
venier attenzione cannavacciuolo ecco
almeno siamo usciti dalla musica perché
la musica proprio non aveva un senso che
cosa loro e attenzione che cosa ci
avviciniamo alla comicità potrebbe avere
un senso che cozzalone ragazzi che con
zalone questa è una brutta scelta e
attenzione che ecco il buon che covo
portarmi lilly in qualche modo brignano
brignano enrico brignano posso cliccar e
quello per ospite che avete un attimo
sotto se qualcosa anche a che è che
tempo che fa eccolo eccolo che tempo che
fa posso ammettere che tempo che fa
perché che dunque fa sono andati per il
film soldi per il film a due giovani e
giacomo quindi forse se vado sottoli
becco forse li becca maledizione ragazzi
ci sia perché sono andati recentemente
quindi se becco un comico a che tempo
che fa io peccato
[Musica]
sto andando sugli ultimi e perché era
più eccoli porco demonio ci ho messo un
sacco oraria cha verso il sun è stato
difficile perché vi sono dovuti
incartare per beccare quello
dell'intervista di che tempo che fa però
ce l'abbiamo fatta sparire ragazzi
allora abbiamo scherzato questa è pensa
che questa era più facile
non sto scherzando adesso dovremmo
passare dalle corona vyrus a gli one
direction
[Musica]
allora era già allora vi dico che già è
difficile perché comunque stiamo
parlando di cose che non c'entrano
assolutamente nino che devono c'entrasse
moto o aldo giovanni e giacomo però
fortunatamente c'è stato sanremo quindi
fortunatamente ci sono consigliati di
sanremo e già andiamo subito sul cantato
andiamo sul cantato che non è ma la
prima volta di fa vj certo perché non
metterlo con i correlati del corona
vyrus non lo so tipo 23 i con la cerchia
non italiana perché se io continuo nella
cerca italiana è un casino però hanno
fatto ragazzi qualche ospite
international sanremo qualsiasi esso sia
asi claudio baglioni appunto se volete
chimiche in tutto sto casino non c'è
niente ding le mani ente proprio neanche
per sbaglio va bene rete slater va bene
ultimo andiamo sull'ultimo che tanto e
gabry ponte o tu sei alla fine sta
canzone mi salva sempre il culo in che
modo
gabry ponte gli aprì ponte e ovviamente
io prima ho detto devo trovare il ponte
e gabri fonte dal ponte per fece non
l'hotel non l'ho detto pensandolo
davvero ma effettivamente lui è l'unico
ponte che ho nel vero senso della parola
per beccarvi con i dj di fama mondiale
dj antoine o la one is my cherie allora
anzi nota di bianchi o finalmente siamo
usciti dal vortice italiano allora lui
sforzi ci siamo dai gli sforzi pian
piano siamo ci siamo siamo nel giro
ragazzi ci siamo
andiamo solo beccare un qualche cosa che
si avvicini ai gusti delle ragazzine del
2012 porco davis punta per qualche
strano motivo a caso mi dovrebbero
spuntare naomi è quello che ha fatto
shirley da jason derulo ed air one
direction e buttano lì ma che cosa che
ti costa butta però la one direction
forte poi vai veloce mezza nuda in mezzo
al nulla poi emesso jason derulo mi
metti lingua direction one direction
che palle non lo trovo fa il secondo
summer non mi metti un correlato day one
direction ma un correlatore uno zio
buono ma quanto tempo
quanto tempo e far uscire un video day
one direction madonna ragazzi proprio
trend è andato giù di bestia day one
direction non è male anche uno banton e
basta sono stanco
questa ragazza un po difficile dovrà
passare da il castello errante di howl
ad achille lauro
[Musica]
dico la verità in realtà non è così
difficile perché siccome c'è sanremo il
propone robe di sanremo al caso quindi
teoricamente dovrebbe care sanremo e poi
non dovrebbe esser quanto siano lontani
sanremo me lo propone quasi subito
secondo me perché il periodo e quindi se
becco killer auge breve sarà abbastanza
easy poi vediamo allora riteniamo
supportivo non vedo perchè devo uscire
ultimo come il castello errante però
andiamo su un ultimo e dopo ultimo
tiziano ferro attenzione achille lauro
mamma mia questo è stato molto easy
rispetto al solito che sei record tra
l'altro credo il prossimo
non so neanche da dove cominciare però
cominciamo da pustola addio brando
no no no ecco l'unico video che avendo
composto dalle nuove rischia il gusto
dell'argento gusti schifosi muffa
putrida posto l'auto rosa mutanda
tiscione e l'unico che posso cliccar e
scusate vi dobbiamo arrivare a giorgio
anzi non agio a dino brando neanche a
giorgio che sarebbe troppo facile
il ragazzo che fa recensioni di manga
che ho cliccato all'inizio potrebbe
essermi molto utile vediamo se riesco
arrivarci unico nome si chiama mangaka
96 tipo riusciamo l'asta cagata di
postola per favore da richard htt
disegno disegno già ci avviciniamo un po
ai manga in qualche modo vediamo that
not that not perfetto per me brava fra
produrrà va sempre fran frodi correlati
di fra foro che sono fra frog basse raf
rogo che dice ad htt fra frode va bene
mangiato i disegni disegni di favi gesto
video bellissimo dai ragazzi un manga
death note
la verità alla sua stringata nota il ma
io sud apple ok nascosta dl va bene in
compuware sospresa quindi giovedì che
stiamo arrivando su dragon ball va bene
se spuntasse un giorgio sarebbe
veramente il top del top proprio però
vabbè dragon ball da mac ken il
guerriero attenzione ken il guerriero
già siamo più o meno li più o meno è
ragazzi mi sto veramente buttando troppo
su dragon ball femminili veramente
negativo perché poi non esce niente
altro che dragon ball quindi qualcosa
che non sia dragon ball qualsiasi cosa
che cos'è lo sporting grazie rocco
questo momento è proprio quello che
volevo cliccare le mani di dio dio dio
dio dio dio dio peccato dio le mani di
dio c'è di oggi
dragonball quindi c'entra niente però
dio
magari vado niente studio brando senza
anche passare a ioni o troppo di
operando nei commenti credi come
manovale bavarian o non vale non devo
trovarlo nei commenti dai solo lui che
si chiama dio brando vada mai ci
sollecita tali commenti che non c'entra
niente
va da sé che sfiga deve essere nel
titolo purtroppo quindi non un post da
ma che spiega ho trovato un dio brando e
sta mettendo tutti i dialoghi tutti i
personaggi manca solo dio brando giorgi
a dio le stesse gioca lo zio presso
mille anni ma non è ancora finito perché
dio brando deve esserci scritto quindi
porco devono ancora finito però almeno
se variati appoggio 8 ore 8 ore per gli
arancio l'incredibile deve esserci sito
di operando dunque in tutto questo addio
operando
[Musica]
[Applauso]